oui
[Musique]
non un vieux proverbe hongrois dit qu'on
ne peut mettre tout le monde sous un
même chapeau ce qui signifie les mêmes
règles ne peuvent être appliquées à tous
et tout ça et pourtant c'est exactement
ce à quoi budapest s'est engagé lorsque
la hongrie a rejoint l'union européenne
en 2004 devenant rapidement le fils
prodigue préféré de l'europe accusé au
fil des ans de tous les péchés possible
envers la démocratie que pense le
gouvernement au ban de sa place et de
son avenir dans la famille européenne
pour en parler se joint à moi le
ministre hongrois des affaires
étrangères et du commerce 8h06 jarre tôt
monsieur le ministre c'est un plaisir de
vous revoir merci de nous vous m'avez
entendu mentionné ce proverbe populaire
selon lequel ne faut pas mettre tout le
monde sous un même chapeau mais je sais
qu'il ya un autre dicton hongrois une
sorte de conseil ne s'allongent et que
dans la limite de sa propre couverture
et mais ces jours ci la couverture
hongroise s'étale je dirais assez loin
vous venez souvent en russie vous avez
des relations solides avec la chine et
de nombreux autres pays mais il semble
que dans l'union européenne qui est
votre maison et votre famille votre pays
soit encore un peu traitée comme
l'enfant terrible
pourquoi selon vous
et bien pas qu'un peu vous savez
il y à un grand débat dans l'union
européenne à l'heure actuelle pour
savoir à quoi lui e devra ressembler à
l'avenir et je pense que le fait que ce
débat ait lieu doit être considérée
comme naturelle
car en fait l'union européenne a été
simultanément confrontée à de nombreux
défis
donc évidemment dans le contexte actuel
il est normal d'avoir un débat sur la
façon d'aller de l'avant
et il y a deux approches de base à cet
égard une approche consiste à créer
quelque chose comme les états unis
d'europe il s'agit donc d'une approche
assez fédéraliste dont les représentants
aimerait fondamentalement dépasser
l'identité nationale l'héritage chrétien
et en même temps le plus de compétences
possibles devrait être transféré à
bruxelles ce fait leur position
mais il ya une autre approche dont les
représentants il faut l'admettre sont
maintenant aux minorités c'est une sorte
d' approche souverainiste qui affirme
que oui nous voulons une union
européenne forte mais nous estimons
qu'une union européenne forte ne peut
reposer que sur des états membres forts
en préparant cet entretien ça a été
intéressant pour moi de regarder
certaines de vos interviews de 2015 et
2016 concernant la crise migratoire
beaucoup de journalistes occidentaux en
particulier britanniques et allemands
ont fustigé la hongrie de ne pas être
suffisamment accueillante envers les
migrants pris
comparez cela avec la couverture de la
crise migratoire actuelle à la frontière
entre la biélorussie la pologne le
niveau d'indignation mort à aller
beaucoup plus bas
comment perçois ton à budapest cette
attitude changeantes en matière
d'ouverture face aux migrations
écoutez j'ai le luxe d'être à ce poste
depuis plus de sept ans maintenant donc
je me souviens clairement qui a dit quoi
il ya 5 6 ans quand
il n'y a que trois ministres des
affaires étrangères européens qui se
trouvent dans la même situation qu'en
2015 et je me souviens de la façon dont
nous avons été vraiment attaqué à
l'attitude envers nous était vraiment
très hostile
et ceux qui nous ont traités de manière
très grossière ovationnent désormais
ceux qui agissent de la même manière que
nous en 2015
notre position reste inchangée les
frontières extérieures de l'union
européenne doivent être protégés
la possibilité de décider à qui vous
autoriser l'entrée dans votre pays fait
partie de votre souveraineté et c'est
votre droit souverain de choisir avec
qui vous êtes prêts à vivre
monsieur le ministre vous venez de dire
que votre position n'avait pas changé
mais je pense qu il est également clair
que la position européenne sur la
question de la migration a évolué elle
n'est plus basée sur une politique on
pourrait qualifiée d' invitation
explicite
l'autre jour j'ai regardé sur deux chez
bell et d'interviews de l'un des
architectes allemands de l'accord
migratoire avec la turquie et il
appelait ouvertement à déplacer ces
migrants de la frontière polonaise vers
le cren non pas vers l'allemagne mais
vers l'ukraine de toute évidence même
les allemands ne se pressent plus pour
accueillir ces personnes
selon vous qu'est ce qui a changé en
europe sur cette question au cours des
cinq dernières années
vous savez je pense qu'il ya une grande
hypocrisie nous avons entendu certains
des commentaires que vous évoquez et qui
donne l'impression que les pays d'europe
occidentale ont changé de position en
matière de migration
ce qui est du soutien aux ong pro
migration de la route migratoire dans
les balkans quand il s'agit de faire des
déclarations responsable concernant la
situation en afghanistan en méditerranée
il peut y avoir des commentaires qui
semble être différent par rapport à ce
qui a été dit depuis 2015
mais l'essence de la politique
migratoire européenne reste
malheureusement la même
si vous regardez le document la
déclaration ou le document fondateur de
la nouvelle coalition gouvernementale
allemande vous verrez que cela reste
extrêmement promis graciant
parlant de l'allemagne la chancelière
allemande angela merkel a été la
principale force motrice de cette
politique de 2015 ainsi que le principal
architecte de la politique
multiculturelle au sein de l'union
européenne elle est en train de quitter
ses fonctions mais je pense que tous les
décideurs politiques responsables
essaient d'anticiper l'avenir
comment pensez vous que son départ
affectera à la fois le dialogue interne
et externe qui a lieu à l'intérieur et
autour de l'union européenne
c'est intéressant parce que il faut
examiner cela en parallèle avec la
prochaine présidentielle française
après la prochaine élection
présidentielle en france vous aurez une
nouvelle configuration des dirigeants
des deux pays les plus forts de l'union
bien sûr
l'allemagne est notre partenaire numéro
un en matière de commerce et
d'investissement donc une relation
pragmatique avec ce pays basé sur le
respect mutuel est importante pour nous
malheureusement ces derniers temps en
particulier les partis allemands de
gauche et les médias nous attaquent
constamment
dans ce qui concerne par exemple nos
relations avec la russie
alors même que le projet north stream ii
est fondamentalement un projet commun
germano russe
lors de ma visite dans la région de
kalouga j'ai vu deux grands panneaux
d'affichage des entreprises présentes à
kalouga et ce sont les plus grandes
sociétés allemandes françaises
italiennes espagnoles
elles sont plus qu'heureuse de
travailler en russie en même temps
d'insulter la russie c'est ça cela
m'amène à une autre question croyez vous
qu'il existe un lien entre la puissance
de l'union européenne sa capacité à
résoudre des problèmes pratiques et sa
propension à critiquer les autres pays
ou à utiliser des invectives verbales ou
et biologiques je pense que oui est ce
que ces choses sont interdépendantes je
veux dire il injurie la russie et la
hongrie mais ils font toujours à faire
avec nous cela at il un impact en termes
pratiques oui c'est une énorme
hypocrisie
parce que ce qui se passe c'est que les
pays grands efforts peuvent se permettre
de dire une chose et agir différemment
les petits pays ne peuvent pas se le
permettre vous aussi vous faîtes
entendre votre voix mais c'est vrai vous
n'êtes pas un petit pays mais nos
paroles correspondent à nos actes et
nous ne pouvons pas nous permettre que
nos actes ne soit pas à la hauteur de
nos paroles
ce que les occidentaux font ces
critiques et la russie et en même temps
faire affaire avec vous c'est à dire que
leurs paroles vont à l'encontre de leurs
actes où il attaque la chine et nous
mêmes pour coopérer avec vous et la
chine et alors qu'il conclut d'énormes
accord avec les chinois c'est ça que je
voulais dire un tel comportement ne
présente que des mauvais côtés où il ya
aussi des avantages
non cela fait beaucoup de mal et je vais
expliquer pourquoi il faut prendre en
considération la réalité si vous
regardez la réalité on voit que la chine
a fait passer sa part dans le pib
mondial de 4 % à 18 % en vingt ans
les etats unis restent au même niveau
plus ou moins de 31 ou 30 % à 25 %
l'année dernière les etats unis ont eu
un plus grand volume des changes avec la
chine et avec tous les états membres de
l'ua réunis et les états membres de l'ue
eux ont plus échangé avec les chinois
qu'avec les américains nous devons donc
tenir compte de la réalité sans parler
du fait que la plus grande zone de libre
échange au monde a aussi été créé à
l'est et que 70% de tous les
investissements mondiaux ont été
financées par des capitaux orientaux
l'année dernière et seulement 30% par
des capitaux occidentaux donc ce genre
d'approché hypocrite dont lui ai fait
malheureusement preuve nuit aux intérêts
européens et comme nous sommes une
partie intégrante de l'union européenne
nous intéressons également lésés vous
avez mentionné les états unis et pour
autant que je sache la hongrie n'a pas
été invité au prochain sommet pour la
démocratie que l'administration by then
s'efforce d'organiser en fait que la
hongrie est le seul membre de l'union
européenne qui a été en quelque sorte
laissé de côté et l'un des deux états
membres de l'otan ça fait mal non
vous savez nous sommes un pays avec un
état chrétien riche
d'une histoire de milan
notre histoire est parsemé de lutte pour
la liberté et la souveraineté
mais nous n'avons besoin d'aucun acteur
ou facteurs externes pour juger de
l'état de notre démocratie
nous ne sommes pas des élèves de 4e qui
doivent être préparés pour un examen de
fin d'année
[Musique]
monsieur le ministre quand c'est injuste
c'est injuste
tout à fait c'est ce que je fourre tout
personne c'est pénible oui mais encore
une fois nous n'avons pas besoin d'un
juge
nous sommes conscients de notre
situation nous sommes fiers de notre
démocratie fiers de nos combats pour la
liberté au cours de notre histoire fier
des 1000 dernières années et nous
n'avons besoin de personne pour
certifier sa
d'accord permettez-moi de reformuler la
question car votre gouvernement
entretenait des relations assez
chaleureuse avec l'administration tran
huy
ce qui pour autant que je sache n'est
pas tout à fait le cas avec l'équipe
baden et je pense que c'est joe biden
qui lors de sa campagne électorale à
comparer votre gouvernement un régime
totalitaire vous et moi nous avons tout
est étudié les sciences politiques à la
fac et nous savons que le totalitarisme
est un système bien définis
scientifiquement doté de certaines
caractéristiques qui quoi que l'on pense
de la hongrie ni sont pas présentes
s'ils ont une telle mauvaise
compréhension de la définition du
totalitarisme dans quelle mesure
comprennent s'il la démocratie non pas
comme une étiquette politique ou un
outil et rhétorique mais comme un
système de gouvernance
l'écouté je ne pense pas qu'il se soucie
trop de la réalité de la démocratie non
de la réalité dans nos pays à
[Musique]
ce qu'ils disent de nous n'a rien à voir
avec la réalité
ils ont une approche idéologique
totalement différente de celle que nous
adoptons
je me souviens même parce que j'étais là
avant 2016 pour sous l'ancienne
administration démocrate
nous ont beaucoup critiqué pour avoir
introduit une nouvelle constitution en
hongrie
reposant sur une base chrétienne
et ils nous ont reproché d'avoir trop
prioriser nos intérêts nationaux
de ce point de vue nous avons une vision
du monde totalement différente
je ne dis pas que c'est un problème car
nous sommes différents nous pouvons
penser différemment
j'estime que le seul problème à cet
égard et qu'il n'y a pas de respect
mutuel
parce que nous respectons la décision
des citoyens américains nous respectons
la façon dont ils veulent aller de
l'avant
nous respectons celui qui l'ont élu
comme président mais ce genre de respect
n'est pas accordée à la hongrie il ya
beaucoup de mensonges de fausses
nouvelles et d' insultes visant la
hongrie et le premier ministre lui même
qui s'est personnellement battus pour la
liberté
monsieur le ministre prenant une courte
pause restez avec nous
[Musique]
messieurs les ministres avant la pause
nous discutions des efforts visant à
faire que la hongrie se sentent exclus
de la société
mais j'ai remarqué au cours des 2
dernières mois que budapest était devenu
une sorte de lieu de rencontre pour
l'europe dans son ensemble et je
souligne dans son ensemble parce que
lorsque mes amis russes ou par exemple
britannique veut se rencontrer quelque
part en europe en ces temps de
désagréments liés à la situation
sanitaire budapest semble être un
endroit idéal où la position
géographique et la réglementation se
rejoignent de manière pratique est ce
une coïncidence ou essayez vous en effet
de faire de votre capital en carrefour
réguler et en même temps facilement
accessible entre l'est et l'ouest
écoutez nous sommes un pays d'europe
centrale donc nous avons toujours été
entre l'ouest et l'est
nous essayons d'exploiter cette position
vous voulez dire que c'est intentionnel
et bien sûr parce que vous savez cette
stratégie se manifeste également dans
notre politique étrangère nous avons
toujours voulu que l'est et l'ouest et
des relations pragmatiques et un
dialogue continu pourquoi parce que
notre histoire nous a appris que à
chaque fois qu'il ya eu un conflit entre
l'est et l'ouest les pays d'europe
centrale dont la hongrie ont toujours
perdu et nous ne voulons plus perdre
donc quand nous plaidons en faveur du
dialogue des relations pragmatiques du
respect mutuel ou de la confiance
mutuelle ce n'est pas parce que nous
serions des espions c'est tout
simplement ridicule et ce n'est pas une
rhétorique creuse c'est dans votre
intérêt c'est notre intérêt national pur
et simple
sans parler du fait que nous avons eu
beaucoup de succès pour ce qui est de la
vaccination
et comme nous avons réussi surtout au
début de la campagne
nous avons tué assouplir les
restrictions hongrie en fait c'est grâce
à cela qu'on a pu ouvrir budapest et le
pays aux visiteurs aux voyageurs
également nous avons signé de nombreux
accords bilatéraux avec d'autres pays
mme koulouris compris avec la russie
dont je veux vous parler
il ya un accord sur la reconnaissance
mutuelle des certificats de vaccination
entre nos deux pays et pour autant que
je sache les hongrois ont également
choix assez large de vaccins
vous avez vous même choisi le vaccin
spoutnik v
pourquoi pensez-vous que vos voisins
européenne ne font-ils pas de même
y at il une raison politique à cela et
si oui quels avantages réels qu'on
pourrait s'y récit toute l'europe
accepté de coopérer dans cette lutte
vous savez je ne trouve vraiment pas de
mots décrire ce que je ressens à propos
du fait qu'il y encore beaucoup de pays
qui considèrent les questions de
vaccination et comme si elle avait un
caractère politique ou idéologique
il s'agit de la vie des gens
pour vous il s'agit de la vie des gens
mais pour eux qu'est ce que c'est
c'est une question de débat politique et
idéologique que pensez vous qu'ils en
tirent je ne sais pas les citoyens
meurent le monde des affaires souffrent
à cause de cela je n'ai pas de réponse à
cela pour être honnête je n'en ai aucune
idée je suis très frustré à ce sujet je
vous dirai pourquoi la réglementation
européenne parle très clairement de la
façon dont un vaccin peut être approuvée
sur le territoire de l'union européenne
il y à deux voies tout d'abord cela se
fait par l' agence européenne des
médicaments ce qui est la manière
habituelle d'approuver un vaccin mais la
réglementation européenne jusqu'à la
nationale 10 qu'en cas d'état d'urgence
comme celui ci les régulateurs nationaux
sont également autorisées a approuvé les
vaccins sur une base temporaire donc
avant que nous commencions à utiliser à
la fois spoutnik v b sinopharm chinois
notre régulateur national a approuvé
l'utilisation des deux vaccins ce qui
signifie que l'utilisation de spoutnik
les angles est basée sur une
réglementation européenne vous voyez et
chaque fois que je parle à mes collègues
d'europe occidentale entre quatre yeux
il m'assure toujours qu'ils savent que
la performance scientifique russe ne
peut être qualifié que de très hautes
et bien c'est l'un des accents les plus
efficaces sinon le bac sans le plus
efficace ils en sont certains c'est ce
qu'il me dise à huis clos ils sont sûrs
que soutenu devait fonctionne bien et je
leur dis regardez c'est celui qui marche
le mieux bien sûr que cela fonctionne
bien les experts hongrois l'ont approuvé
mais indépendamment de l'opinion qu'ils
expriment tous en privé ils agissent
totalement autrement au public mais si
vous le regardez sous un autre angle
du point de vue de votre intérêt
national cela ne vous donne-t-il pas un
avantage plus ils attendent plus vous
pouvez gagner non seulement de par votre
position centrale en europe mais aussi
de je sais que vous avez des projets de
fabrication de ce pique nique vais sur
votre territoire national donc vous
tirer profit de l'absence d'action de
vos voisins européens en fait nous en
avons beaucoup tiré profit surtout au
début pendant le premier semestre de
cette année les livraisons des
fabricants occidentaux étaient parfois
tardive il arrivait qu elle soit même
annulé ou que le volume soit moindre par
rapport à ce qui était prévu par le
contrat à cette époque le fait que des
volumes supplémentaires de sinopharm et
de spoutnik v nous aient été livrés à
temps nous a donné un énorme avantage
par rapport aux autres on a pu rouvrir
le pays et relancer l'économie nationale
environ deux mois plus tôt que la
moyenne européenne
grâce à cela vers l'été notre économie a
atteint le niveau de performances
d'avant la pandémie alors que l'ensemble
de l'économie mondiale ne sera capable
de l'atteindre qu'à la fin de l'année
prochaine
cela fait donc un avantage d'un an et
demi donc évidemment cela a apporté
beaucoup davantage sans parler du fait
que pendant le premier semestre de cette
année en raison des mesures restrictives
l'économie nationale perdait 30 millions
d'euros chaque jour donc si on pouvait
simplement alléger les réglementations
le pire c'est pour eux et le meilleur
c'est pour vous vous savez franchement
je ne comprends pas oui je vous posais
une question de nature personnelle bien
sûr que vous pouvez vous avez préféré
fixer à tous les autres vaccins et je
crois que yves accents ont été approuvés
en hongrie 6 au total
chaque fois que vous rencontrez vos
collègues indiens ou chinois par exemple
et ce qui est vous taquine pour avoir
choisi spoutnik vais au détriment des
vies shield
non non jamais j'ai également un très
bon contact avec monsieur le ministre
chinois des affaires étrangères il n'a
jamais évoqué cela je suis sûr que
sergueï lavrov que vous avez rencontrées
avaient été informés de ce choix même
s'il s'agit d'un choix personnel bien
sûr mais pas seulement lui le ministre e
m'entourent off est un ami personnel
monsieur mouche qu aussi nous les avons
récompensé tous les trois car ils ont
joué un rôle très important dans la
signature du contrat et dans les
livraisons dans le cadre du contrat
ce qui m'a poussé à prendre cette
décision est très simple
quand j'étais enfant j'ai été vacciné
par des vaccins fabriqués en russie à
l'époque en union soviétique
et comme je suis en vie comme je vais
bien je me suis dit pourquoi devrais je
changer voilà le motif de ma décision
est très simple pour être honnête
et bien je suis sûr que les responsables
russes seront très heureux d'entendre
cela
aujourd'hui contrairement aux attentes
initiales il semble que le vide 19 soit
là pour rester et peut-être que cela
pèsera beaucoup plus lourd sur les
sociétés que prévu mais je pense que
dans une certaine mesure cela nous a
fait reculer ne renfermait comprendre
que nous sommes tous mortels et que tout
ce qui compte dans cette vie ce sont des
choses concrètes plutôt abstraite
notre famille nos enfants notre santé
notre quartier notre pays le tissu
social dans lequel est intégré vous
savez ce sont ces choses qui aident les
gens à surmonter cette expérience très
difficile et ce sont ces valeurs que
votre gouvernement a défendu et pour
lesquels il a été critiqué pendant de
nombreuses années dans une certaine
mesure sentez vous que la pandémie vous
a donné raison
écoutez je pensais que la pandémie
aurait un impact positif
qu'il y aurait une prise de conscience
par les pays du monde que nous vivons
dans une forte interdépendance
l aéro et j'espérais que les conflits
seraient mis de côté et que les pays
comprendrait que nous devons coopérer
sur des questions telles que la
sauvegarde des vies humaines et fuel
icesave
mais malheureusement ce n'est pas le cas
je suis déçu
on n'a vu aucune action commune du côté
scientifique en matière de vaccins
j'avais un peu d'espoir l'année dernière
alors qu'on faisait la queue en chine
pour acheter des masques les
ventilateurs avec dans des costumes de
protection pour les médecins avec tous
ces pays occidentaux qui fustigeait la
chine auparavant
et je pensais que cela pourrait changer
leurs positions bon qu'il continue à
penser ainsi mais comment les relations
deviendraient plus équilibrée et
respectueuse mais cela ne s'est
malheureusement pas produit il ne reste
très peu de temps donc passons à un
autre sujet ce temps vous avez été
ministre vous avez insisté sur les
intérêts de la sécurité nationale comme
base de votre politique et je me demande
si votre définition de ce qui constitue
les intérêts de la sécurité nationale de
la hongrie a changé au cours des deux
dernières années parce que vous avez
mentionné qu'il y avait beaucoup de
sermons sur l'unité et l'action commune
et que le coït 19 avaient démontré que
lorsque la situation s'aggraver tout le
monde mettait ses propres affaires au
premier plan cela vous at-il fait
changer votre vision du fonctionnement
du monde
en fait en ce qui concerne les intérêts
de la sécurité nationale je pense que la
pandémie a montré très clairement que si
vous en tant que pays indépendamment de
la taille et de la position géographique
il ne disposait pas de capacités
stratégiques de possibilités d'actifs
alors vous devenez extrêmement
vulnérables
défense oui chemise cela signifie que
vous devez avoir des capacités qui sont
des circonstances pacifique semble
totalement et en particulier du point de
vue financier
mais lorsqu'une crise survient elles
sont décisifs pour ce qui est de sauver
des vies
nous avons mis en place nos propres
capacités de fabrication de ventilateurs
qu'en costume de protection médicaments
vaccins nous travaillons là-dessus la
construction d'une usine pour fabriquer
des vaccins est en cours nous avons
acheté des avions cargo donc tous ces
types d'actifs et de capacités ont été
créées il y a quelques mois la hongrie à
retirer son contingent en afghanistan à
la suite du retrait soudain des
etats-unis et je sais que malgré votre
ferme position sur l'immigration
vous avez pris soin d'évacuer tous les
afghans plus de 500 personnes qui ont
apporté leur soutien à votre mission
je me demande toutefois si cette
participation à ces missions prolongée
de l'otan s'inscrit toujours dans le
cadre des intérêts de votre sécurité
nationale
en tant que membre de l'otan nous
participons bien sûr toujours à des
actions conjointes ce n'est pas une
question la solidarité est l'essence
même de l'otan je dois dire que la
décision de partir a été prise très
rapidement et si nous sommes honnêtes
envers nous mêmes et je pense que nous
le devrions alors ses vingt années de
missions internationales se sont soldées
par un échec évidemment à ce qu'on
prévoyait de contribuer financièrement
au maintien des forces de sécurité et de
défense nationale afghane jusqu'en 2024
ainsi même nous on broie avons fait des
promesses de dons sur notre budget
national
et quelques jours après où même quelques
jours avant que nous quittions
entièrement l'afghanistan tout s'est
effondré
voilà ce qui s'est passé malheureusement
ça a été un échec mais vous êtes
toujours déterminé à participer à ces
missions à l'avenir en tant que membre
de l'otan il n'y a plus de missions
l'afghanistan mais clairement mais le
seul ministre et ce n'est pas une
question et des halles de ma part car
vous savez qu'il ya des tensions à la
frontière occidentale de la russie à la
frontière avec l'union européenne oui
d'accord on voit aujourd'hui diverses
tensions entre la russie et l'europe
occidentale où la russie et l'otan
et disons si plutôt que quand ces
tensions devait dégénérer en conflit
ouvert oc vous que la hongrie sera
toujours en mesure de rester neutre
qu'on vous le faites avec beaucoup de
succès en ce moment où les circonstances
vous obligeront t elle à prendre parti
ou à prendre la décision de lutter au
nom contre les russes
premièrement nous sommes membres de
l'otan et cela apporte des engagements
et des obligations qu on ne peut jamais
malgré toutes vos critiques à l'égard de
temps bien sûr mais vous ne pouvez pas
dissocier et contenu de toute l'aide
russe dans cette période difficile
attendez attendez c'est pour ça que je
dis que vous ne pouvez pas dissocier ces
deux choses mais encore une fois
deuxièmement nous ferons toujours de
notre mieux pour éviter pour empêcher un
tel conflit entre l'otan et la russie
parce qu'une fois de plus nous vivons en
europe centrale nous savons ce que l'a
fait quand il ya un conflit grave entre
la russie l'union soviétique l'est et
l'ouest east
estimez-vous qu'un petit pays comme la
hongrie petit pays mais passionné et
livrent à la capacité d'influencé de
telles décisions
agde où je pense je pense que personne
c'est mon avis personnel d'accord
avec douche je crois que personne de
saint
yves et même en europe occidentale pour
12,5 ne voudrait qu'un tel conflit
éclate je pense donc tout le monde en
occident oui au duo fera de son mieux
pour éviter un tel conflit j'en suis
plus ou moins sûr
eh bien j'espère que vous avez raison
oui oui j'espère aussi cela a été un
grand plaisir de vous parler merci
beaucoup merci beaucoup
[Musique]